前陣子ChartGT終於推出新的生成圖片模型
Image 2.0了
那這次的2.0終於支援了繁體中文
為什麼說終於支援呢
其實之前就可以生成繁體中文
只是之前生成的繁體中文
有點像是抽卡機率
很常會生成錯誤的中文出來
那這次繁體中文不僅是生成的正確
而且品質非常的好
那今天我們就順便來對比一下
跟Jenry這個Barana 2到底生成圖片的能力
兩者到底有什麼差別呢
往下來看吧
GO
大家好我是阿湯
今天不囉嗦了
直接準備了10個Prompt來生成這個圖片
分別用Gemini跟Charge GT生成之後
我們來看看兩者圖片的這個差異到底在哪裡
以及用下來我自己目前對於Charge GT
新的這個Image 2.0到底有什麼樣的新的呢
前陣子ChartGT升級了Image 2.0這個生成圖片的模型之後
其實最近蠻多人都在測試跟Gemini的Banana 2到底有什麼差別
今天我也這邊稍微來測試給大家看
順便分享一下我自己的心得
這邊也不囉嗦不浪費大家在等待這個生成圖片的時間
這邊指令的圖片我已經全部都生成完畢了
我們就直接一張一張來看就好
首先第一張是超高解析度微距攝影
主要就是機械懷錶裡面
兩個要注意的就是金色儲倫上覆蓋細小灰塵
第二個主發條上會有一滴機油正在滴落
我們來看一下
這個細小灰塵
Geminar這邊都有做到
在Charge GT這邊也有做到
不過在兩個相比之下
這個像機油滴落的部分
我覺得整體的畫面感我比較喜歡Charge GT的
不得不說Charge GT這次Image 2.0
我覺得升級的最大重點之一
並不是說在於說很多人都講說終於支援中文了
我覺得最大的重點在於說
它對於你的文字的理解程度是更高的
所以我覺得在簡單的指令之下
它生成的這個圖片的細節會比起這個German來
我覺得多上不少
簡單的說German來並不是不能生成像ChallocC這一張那麼細的圖片
而是它需要給它指令的文字需要更多一點
描述更詳細,他才有辦法向CHARGD生成這種比較細的圖片來
再來我們來看一下第二張圖片
這張圖片我們主要來看一下對於繁體中文的資源
之前BANANA圖片的生成,大家就已經知道他可以支援繁體中文
但是像CHARGD支援繁體中文這件事情
一直在等他更新,終於等到他的2.0來了
這次的2.0,繁體中文的資源是完全沒有問題的
測試的非常非常多文字
目前還沒有測試到會有錯字的狀況
不過像ChartGT呢
它雖然不會有錯字的狀況
不過在比較小文字的時候
有時候還是會有一些些微的亂碼的狀況
那後面也會帶大家來看一下
不過呢
這兩張圖片不只是繁體中文的這個資源的測試而已
其實就像我們前一張一樣
就簡單的這個文字給它之後
其實我自己個人呢
覺得這兩張生成都沒有問題
但是呢我還是比較喜歡Chargeec生成出來的感覺
我覺得還是比較細一點比較像是真實的圖片感
左邊呢這個是我覺得AI圖片看多了就會覺得他是一張AI的圖片
再來第三張呢是復古美式餐廳黑版的菜單
那粉筆手寫英文
好這個呢我覺得一目了然吧
大家應該會比較喜歡Chargeec這一張這個我想應該就不用多說了跟我前面講的這個概念都是一樣的我覺得Image 2.0真的是對於細節的邏輯的理解是更好一些的
再來第四個就是生成報紙的部分
生成報紙這件事情的最大的重點就是在於細節
好我們直接來放大這個圖片來看一下
好先給大家看一下這是Gamini生成的這個報紙
那它這個文字比較細的時候呢
大家可以看到它其實錯字非常非常非常的多
這個部分其實在像nobu.com上面去生成圖片的簡報的時候
也都會發生的狀況
就當你文字比較密集比較多的時候
這個文字很難很精準的每個字都正確
接下來我們來看一下像treadgpt的這個報紙生成的文字的部分
給大家看一下
基本上我自己很仔細的去看了一下整篇報紙的文字
除了部分一樣會有錯誤之外
可是我覺得在大部分的文字下
它的呈現是比起Gramelite好非常多的
你看只有這邊底下有一些錯誤之外
其他網上基本上所有的字都是正確的
即便是這麼小的狀況下
所以我覺得在比較細節密集文字的表現下
TrackGPT比起Gramelite的表現是更好的
再來我測試的是多國語言同時在一個畫面上去生成
那這個兩邊我覺得生成的都還蠻不錯的
像左邊這個是Gramelite生成的
右邊是CHARGVT
那兩邊我覺得大致上沒什麼太大問題啦
那對於接近的深層
兩邊我自己都還蠻喜歡的
再來第六個呢是針對人物深層的部分
那這個深層呢我直接來一個
一個80多歲的台灣客家阿嬤
那這個深層出來呢
我覺得像左邊這一看就是比較中國風的感覺
那如果你是以台灣客家阿嬤這種照片啊
穿了傳統花布衣
我覺得右邊呢這個比較寫實一點
如果不告訴你這個是AI生成的
基本上應該是認不出來了吧
就是不會覺得他是AI生成的照片
而是真的有拍出這樣的照片的感覺
我們稍微放大一點給大家看一下
不過兩邊的這個皮膚的紋路呢
我覺得呈現都還蠻不錯的
唯一差別就是像這邊還是比較AI感一點
就像我前面講的一樣
都是一樣的狀況
你必須要給Jerman來再多一點描述
你才會達到想要的那種感覺
但是像這次的ChartGD
對於文字的邏輯理解不僅是更強之外
他也會幫你更細化這個圖片的部分
讓他更加的自然
再來是有些人也有測試過
像是深層水循環的示意圖
他會從蒸發凝結降水到淨流
然後你看一下ChartGT這邊對於
這樣的一張示意圖的循環
完全沒有什麼問題
然後這邊是Gmail的部分
Gmail的部分呢
深層出來的這個循環圖呢
基本上跟ChartGT是差不多了
再來是包裝設計的部分
這個部分其實以前呢
Sharegd剛推出深圖的時候呢
就已經很多人玩過了
不過那時候深圖我覺得就已經還蠻不錯的
然後這次升級到Image 2.0之後呢
我再測試一次
我發現Sharegd這個包裝產品的部分呢
確實是真的蠻厲害的
像這兩張
你一樣的這樣指令給他
你會發現其實Germelight這個有點粗糙了一點了
像Sharegd這邊呢
其實細節是蠻滿的
這張圖片呢
你完全可以直接拿去當作廣告宣傳來使用了吧
像這個呢
就真的是蠻AI感的
不過呢像這次的測試下來呢
之前我們都會覺得Banada生土真的還蠻不錯的
都是因為呢
我們呢給他比較完善的指令
他其實生成出來的東西
就真的品質會比較好一點
但是你看我們這次測試的10個指令呢全部都會像這樣比較簡單一點的那ChapGC這邊呢就幫我們補們補上更多細節再來呢 是針對海報的設計的部分海報設計整體設計起來兩邊我覺得問題不大
那唯一的問題呢 一定就是文字密集的部分
那我們一樣把這個圖片來放大稍微看一下
好 您看我們放大到這個細部文字的部分來看呢
你可以看到這邊左邊的German來的文字呢
確實就像我們之前在使用一樣
只要文字比較密集的情況下
大部分 我講的是大部分都會錯字
大部分的中文都會變成這樣子
只有英文的數字這種還是沒什麼問題
但是只要是繁體中文大部分都會直接錯字
然後這邊ChartGD就像我們剛剛測試報紙的狀況差不多
它就是大部分的中文字都會呈現得還蠻不錯的
你看就是已經放大後的細節
你會發現其實只有少部分的文字是稍微黏在一起的感覺
但是以細小文字來說
它大部分生成都是呈現還蠻不錯的
再來我們來測試一下人物的一些變化
以及場景的變化
首先我們來先生成一個像台灣女性武士
然後身穿什麼什麼
然後站在竹林裡面
這個生成出來大致上沒什麼問題啦
不過這個一樣的我覺得
German來這邊給他細節不夠多的情況下
生成出來的內容真的是比較AI感一點
然後像CHYGD這邊生成出來
我覺得會比較真實一點的感覺
一樣的我們這次主要測試的是人物的變化跟場景的變化
首先人物我們先把它換成是一個揮刀的感覺
雖然我覺得GEMINI他有理解我要做的事情大概是什麼
但是他這個拔刀出去然後就單純只是面對那一邊
然後也有做到中景側身45度角的構圖
電影動作的風格
只不過我覺得他這個揮刀比較沒有揮刀感覺
再呢,ChartGD呢,對我的指令的理解呢
我覺得也沒有到非常的完善
因為比如說我是要中頸側身45度角構圖
你看喔,這個是已經近景了
然後這個中頸應該要再更遠一點才對
但是它變成好像更近景了
然後它也沒有45度角的這個構圖了
它也是都正面的
所以在場景的理解上呢,這兩邊我覺得
Gamini理解比較好
但是呢,ChartGD給我的圖是比較好看的
然後人物的五官兩邊都是沒什麼變化到
這個點倒是還不錯
再來往下這個從竹林高處俯瞰
一樣是同一張圖片
然後呢
動作你看這兩個是沒有變化的
是一樣的
他原本是這個動作
然後到這邊還是這個動作
只是角度變成從竹林上空這樣俯瞰下去
但是有一點遠就是了
我們來看一下Chartgy這邊生成又怎麼樣呢
一樣的是改成比較高空俯瞰
然後同一個角色
然後動作一模一樣
基本上這個部分我覺得算是有一樣的呈現啦
不過你如果細看的話你會發現
他這刀子原本是在刀鞘的上面
但是這邊變成在刀鞘的下面
如果仔細看的話其實是不太一樣
那這邊其實大致上是都差不多的
不過這邊以高空俯瞰來說的話
這邊我覺得好一點
這邊是真的有點太遠了
再來我們用真實的照片來測試一下
直接換場景的部分
像這個呢用我自己的照片
衣服換成西裝
場景換成辦公室來開會
給大家看一下
你看他直接
一模一樣的照片
直接換過來這裡
不太像在開會的感覺
像Charge E這邊有換過來
也有在開會的感覺
這個我覺得好一點
你看他會自動幫我把手
換成是拿筆
可是像這邊就沒有
他直接照我原本的樣子
直接替換過來辦公室場景而已所以就像我講了很多次了Gamrmry對文字的理解其實沒有什麼問題只不過他在細節上沒有幫我想的更多延伸
但是像ChurchGD一樣一句指令而已
他會幫我想好這邊是辦公室
所以我的人物應該要怎麼去呈現比較好
所以這兩者其實有些差別的
然後像五官的部分呢
兩邊我覺得呈現上是不會差異太多的啦
最後一個我們再來測試一下人物
就是換個角度的部分
比如說我這個原本是正面
然後我們要轉到我的側面的畫面
我們看一下像
German來這邊轉到側面的畫面
他是直接幫我把人物轉側面
像這個也是幫我把人物轉側面
不過人物的五官變化上
German來的變化比較少一點
像TrackGPG的五官
我覺得就變化有比較多一點的感覺了
其實我也測試過
如果你在同一張五官
一直變化照片的話
其實如果你變化到第五第六次之後
那Germini的這個一致性的維持還是比較好一點
那像TrapGCT呢
它如果變化到第五第六次之後
這五官其實也會變了一些些掉了
所以最後我們稍微再來統整一下
就是像Germini跟TrapGCT這樣測試下來
對我來說到底差異在哪裡
首先第一個就是我們前面也提到了
TrapGCT它對於文字生成的理解上
邏輯會更加細然後更好一點
像每張照片比對下來
ChartGD的細節都會生成的更好一點
然後對於我想要的內容也都理解的沒有問題
再來第二個就是中文字的部分
中文字兩邊都有支援的
主要最大差別就是報紙比較密集文字的生成
像我們如果是在Gymlite那邊利用圖片生成簡報的時候
比較細的文字很容易就錯字了
但是像CHARGD這邊文字的錯誤率就少非常多
如果German來這邊的密集文字的錯誤率
如果是70%的話
CHARGD這邊大概只有10%到20%而已
其實非常非常的低
簡單的說我覺得CHARGD現在可以用更少的文字來描述這個圖片的需求
然後就能創造出更細緻、更好、更有品質或是更自然這個圖片出來
那German9目前的Banada 2呢
他一樣是需要比較多的文字描述
才能生成出品質非常好的圖片
不過我想呢
ChartGD這個Image 2.0
也已經等了好久才推出啦
我相信German9這邊搞不好已經準備好
Banada 3.0在等大家了
那我們可能就來等等看
之後的更新又會變成什麼樣子囉
看完上面的測試跟介紹之後
不曉得大家會選擇ChartGD還是German9來生成圖片呢
我自己呢覺得如果你想要生成跟設計比較相關的
就比如說網頁設計啊圖片設計這一類的
我覺得呢
Gamlight這邊生成還是比較厲害一點
但是以其他照片的品質來說的話
或者像文字秘籍這種細緻度
我覺得目前還是CHAR-GD略勝一籌啦
不過呢必須得說呢這個Image 2.0推出的時間點呢
已經是在Banada 2之後過了很久才推出的
所以我想呢接下來Banada 3一推出
應該又會在碾壓 ChargeGD的 Image 2.0 吧
這個也不好說啦
那這個部分呢
基本上我們就是靜觀其變
看這些神打架就好啦
今天影片我們就分享到這邊
如果喜歡這影片
別忘了按讚訂閱分享
還有開啟小鈴鐺
如果想要知道更多 AI 相關教學的話
別忘了在底下留言告訴我哦
我是阿湯 下次見
掰掰